[Music]
in redefining labeled news this was
submitted by weekends with JK when girls
are starting to be replaced by men and
boxing matches what maybe there's a big
gay audience now like why do we need
ring people like because they're hot
look - look at that is Trudeau like cuz
now with the cameras being in the
corners is like it's no reason and you
have the big-ass [ __ ] like though
usually standing at the bottom of it of
the screen yeah there's really no need
for ring girls anymore I will say since
porn ring girls are pretty tame down Tom
I got ring girls a [ __ ] like that's
your grandmother in the ring she might
as well Jimmy walk around the wing with
a cane honestly that fully clothed in
his full swimsuit like it's no nip-slip
say anything like really cold in a
swimsuit yeah that's still pretty now
it's not that great after I've seen the
inside of a girl's [ __ ] getting
opened up by a speculum you just don't
care that much about bikinis shots and
stuff like that I never understood it's
like how when you were a kid your
parents made you cover your eyes for
like undressing Sam the girls are not
bra panties but like going to the beach
completely fine yeah and they're
basically the same thing same thing is
under way guys I know with underwear
it's a little bit thinner so there's a
lot less to the imagination the same
only if you're looking at the like that
the vagina yeah right but if it's just
like like I'm talking in the movies like
from the 90s early 2000 it was just like
big jaws not even like dogs just like
jaws and balls it's like that's a
bathing suit bro
especially my wife's ass this is the
nothing's covered nothing ya know it's a
man's incredible but nothing's gonna
cover it yeah listen understand yeah so
after days of local lawmakers and
activists in Australia calling out fight
promoters for using ring girls the the
fight organizer there made a change and
decided to change the girls with so we
got a lot of gay audience members like
hey man we want to see some
got there what was it ladies like hey
man we want to see some nice [ __ ]
like hard AB dudes like [ __ ] standing
there holding them numbers and stuff so
for example a council member said
tourism can wait the future of women and
girls cannot I'd love to raise in my
colleagues about how this is an OK thing
it's not okay that we have young females
portrayed in this way if the sport has
merit on its own it can stand without
these token trophy women and these
accessories that are somehow being
translated as part of the glamour if
this is about true athleticism and skill
they don't need people standing behind
them in black cocktail dresses but
that's part of the tradition though I
like it has nothing to do it sucks oh
yeah what if eyes nothing that did you
see a picture one ouch what if there's
nothing to do with a horrible you want
to end the jobs of women is Christmas
horrible are you against Christmas now
to man now he can't [ __ ] work because
all these lame asses so they said
because what about the military flag
boys is that necessary when they come
out before like any game and they got to
come out with the flag traditional and
it's ceremonial I'm not saying get rid
of all tradition but I'm saying some
tradition is just not good why is this
not good guys flag toys see and that's
not an object of objectification it
again the women in the stands called the
flag boys flag toys yeah but the men
don't have the same they didn't have the
same [ __ ] scrutiny and history that
women have had yeah but women are
beautiful to look at and men or not yeah
but it's awesome look at guys guys guys
can appreciate a good-looking woman just
as much as a woman can appreciate a
good-looking woman you guys don't have
to be lesbians
you all are by to say oh my god banging
that's body
I will never say even I can look at l
bought has a in shape and penis has a
bangin hands body I can tell the way
these shirt is like hugging this is
muscle yeah I would never let yo working
why could get to dick like you would
never [ __ ] get it I won't even
compliment him he could have on the
bangin ass off it others like I should
look cheap like that's just not how like
guys can you know you should be able to
be free enough to say hey you got a bag
but it's not pretty
Bart Burt does not have a pretty body we
complement okay that's you yes women do
have a way more they have wave of Utah
can hold hands walking down the mall
together y'all change in front of each
other
top and bottom no no I've just seen it
I've seen it I've seen it happen but my
point to this is that we're more than
our looks but what's wrong with the ring
girl and what's wrong it's what's wrong
with that job it's just jealous ass
[ __ ] let's be real it doesn't do
anything for the split so are the two
boxers in the ring they're being
objectified there's that little sysm
they're skilled involved with it our
Sports Illustrated models objective
they're not getting rid of it they're
just adding men now to the mix so
they've opened it up and now they're
being equal what why do you need to do
that why do you got to add guys should
be able to use your body submit earn a
living I think I don't understand why
they're adding guys to the mix if
they're just trying to get the girls off
okay okay so first of all they had these
women right there's these four women who
are the ring girls and so because of all
this like I'll cry then the organizer
said all right I'm gonna replace these
women with men so now these women don't
heyguys more now so now they don't have
anymore do the job that they applied for
give them more guys jobs
taking their job and the jobs away from
women female male the [ __ ] more than
male mo that's fine that these women
were still going to be paid even though
they're not gonna do the job so they're
like they were sitting on the sidelines
what here the guys were the ones with
those ladies is a troll basically it
feels like every time that a new round
happened and the guys came out all the
entire crowd was booing okay Macklin um
so then towards the end they brought the
chicks back and then they started
cheering so even like the community has
voted yeah people the organizer said
that ironically format women will be
fighting tonight oh three ring girls by
the way will be fighting tonight and
wearing less clothing than those women I
have now had to replace with men in
response to these protests they have
denied three women the opportunity to do
the job they applied for they are
intelligent women their freedom to work
in an environment that they choose and
enjoy doing has been completely
undermined these protests are an attack
on them and so they are so this
organizer were just saying like you know
it's part of the sport kind of thing but
what part of the sport the man is a
tradition yeah but doing it I know in
Mexico there was a tradition that even
here when you as soon as a girl bleed
she's ready to get married that doesn't
necessarily mean it's right it doesn't
mean it's wrong even what I'm saying is
okay for this the Equality that I see
yeah is in combat sports
there's females fighting now yeah and
with female fighters there's still
female ring girl my bad because it's a
party why do you need ropes why do we
need these strippers why do we need
Instagram thoughts what do we need
teachers well let me say this these
[ __ ] are making money with their
bodies and I think did that slowly chill
you do want to shout them down don't you
you want to shout down these poor
Institute's trying to make weight I have
been super excited to shop places where
I have not been able to and I don't want
to be seen you thinking to continue to
lose weight so I can like take a shirt
off like nothing is more exciting to me
to be able to take my shirt off whenever
I want
and I'm working off of my body and I
want people to see it so how do we know
that these women that are being these
rain girls didn't work hard for the body
they have and want people to see and
they get paid for doing something that's
not how it started it started off
oh no no so and because of that that's a
tradition that I'm against that I'm like
wait why does that even need to be it so
what I'm saying is but all of us are now
for sure because that's what they're
know so well sit where all of us are on
the outside there is a tradition why
don't we just ask the rain girls direct
do you feel like you're being
objectified or do you love this job what
do they all love it and some of them
like the attention and why do you want
to take that away a lot of them love it
that promotor girls dude they [ __ ]
get paid well and they like yeah yeah
shits can't wait to be the UFC girl or
there's no promoter dudes booth dudes
all this [ __ ] all go dancers no market
for that but they know what they're
working with they wear the low-cut tops
it's like bartender chicks like they
know what they're doing yeah we went to
a club recently with and then there was
a guy serving I'll be alcohol and stuff
they were with shirtless and [ __ ] yeah I
think they should ask the chicks
themselves are actually doing it if they
want to keep those I just don't like the
argument of oh it's tradition but
there's a market for objectification and
some people are empowered by absolutely
I agree with that but just to go and say
the excuses it's just cuz it's tradition
is what the tradition is to is a
rebuttal to another point and like why
do I do this when I'm like boards
because it's tradition
why do a lot of things that we do yeah
why do we put our hand over our hearts
like this it's just we've been doing
things that girls are a beautiful
tradition why do we kneel to pray to God
yeah cuz you're humbling yourself yeah
you're still humbling yourself you would
you sing your praises up to God and
that's why the ring girl walks out
chairs to go higher so we can hum
ourselves look at him look how you
brought that fool like round number
three you just walking up let me ask you
a question yeah do you think that women
should be able to do what they want with
their bodies cuz I sure do me yeah -
that's empower me that is man thank you
that is yeah yeah I agree
and so I think prostitution should also
be legal as well
you agree with that look that's
objectifying women because you would
look through a catalogue of them the
thing that I was the thing that I
welcome batting here was just the going
with the thing of all its traditional
it's tradition I'm like yeah I don't
like it
that's where beating women is
traditional - yeah and that's wrong with
that wait wait a second they were
calling the guy the fight progressed men
fight progress managers by the way which
I thought was really hype progress
managers yeah so this is like from a
different group what is this like City
Council or whatever that's arguing for
them to stop this and they have no
[ __ ] relation to this whole thing so
they're just trying to control a whole
different group of people yeah that they
have no relation to that's just [ __ ]
ridiculous sounds like slavery to be
yeah
you